the cartoon crisis in Denmark was really
about freedom of expression and Free
Press it was quite a challenge for the
Danish government to strike the right
balance but because obviously we also
had to come to calm the waters but I
learned from that crisis that you have
to be firm on certain basic principles
and not compromise and we didn't we were
requested to apologize on behalf of a
newspaper that had published some
cartoons but I think that would be a
slippery slope
whether you sympathize or not with those
cartoons it is a basic principle in any
free society that you can express your
views freely whether it is in a written
form television and movies or even
drawings and cartoons and if you start
to compromise in that basic principle
then you will gradually undermine your
free society and democracy of course in
any democracy
you should also respect a freedom of
religion obviously but it is a basic
feature of any democracy that you are
allowed to have a free and also critical
debate about all issues including
religion so that's the lesson I took
from that crisis
I think people broadly accept that we
have to stand up
for these basic principles and the
Danish government did at that time
though it was a very challenging time